Eh bien, s'ils me disaient que ça ressemblait à une chèvre
mes amies
depuis je pense que c'était une façon
intimidation passive mais j'ai réussi
surtout que nous continuons notre
amitié toujours et j'ai continué à être amis avec
mes amis et moi avons compris que je n'avais pas à
changer quoi que ce soit en moi pour leur plaire
Mon père et ma mère m'ont beaucoup aidé là-dessus.
aussi qu'ils m'ont appris à valoriser mon
voix pour valoriser mon talent à la fin
gardé le vibrato et c'est devenu
dans une fleur ils me signent comme une fille
adolescent était plein de
insécurités et mes parents étaient les
personnes qui ont réaffirmé ma validation
et grâce à eux vous pouvez aller de l'avant